تتجه كرواتيا مع بدايه العام الجديد نحو
اعتماد العمله الاوروبيه الموحده والغاء
الاجراءات الحدوديه امام حمل جوازات السفر
الاوروبيه
فبعد 10 اعوام تقريبا على انضمامها
للاتحاد الاوروبي كرواتيا تعتمد اليورو
كعمله رسميه وتنضموا لمنطقه شنغن حيث قالت
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان انضمام
كرواتيا للاتحاد الاوروبي هو لحظه فخر
[موسيقى]
نا اقوى ويمكن الان لكرواتيا ان تساهم
بشكل كامل في جعل منطقه شنغن اكثر ازدهارا
ومرنه
توسع هو الثمن من نوعه والاول منذ 11 عاما
سيساهم في دعم اقتصاد كرواتيا من خلال
تسهيل كل التعاملات الماليه وتعزيز النظام
المالي فاعتماد اليورو سيخفض شروط
الاستدانه وسط الصعوبات الاقتصاديه التي
تمر بها البلاد التي يبلغ تعدادها
السكانيه نحو اربعه ملايين من السماء
فاقرابه 80% من الاذاعات المصرفيه يغلب
عليها اليورو كما ان معظم الكرواتيين
يفضلون تسجيله وضمان ممتلكاتهم الثمينه
بعمله اليورو وهو ما يعكس عندما ثقتهم
بالعمله المحليه فضلا على ان اقتصاد
كرواتيا يعتمد كثيرا على القطاع السياحي
والذي يمثل نحو 20% من الناتج المحليه
وبالتالي فتح الحدود امام الدول الاوروبيه
سيعطي دفعه قويه لقطاع السياحه لتكون
كرواتيا دوله الاكثر استفاده حيث سي وذلك
للكرواتيين ان يتنقلوا بحريه من دون قيود
داخليه
كرواتيا ستواصل تطبيق اجراءات حدوديه
صارمه على حدودها الشرقيه مع جيرانها من
خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي
كالبوسنه و مونتينيغروبيا